hi I'm Anthony Fisher with Reason TV and
we're here with Jamie Joyce the author
of moonshine a cultural history of
America's infamous liquor Jamie thanks
so much for joining us for having me
a lot of people think of moonshine is
like Prohibition era bathtub liquor and
now it's popular with the Brooklyn
hipsters so what exactly is moving
moonshine is a clear on aged whiskey
generally it's made from corn although
it's been used but people will use
anything that ferments you know
historically use just about anything but
generally it's been corn
it's also been barley it's also been rye
so a grain that's steeped on aged a lot
of times people will call moonshine
whiskey without the wood or bourbon
without the barrel where did moonshine
originate and it's always kind of been
associated with law breaking can you
like separate some of the myths from the
reality yeah moonshining has a long
history in the United States it came
with settlers from from Europe you know
the Ulster region a lot of these yes so
you had a lot of scots-irish coming to
this country bringing these traditions
with them and many of them were settled
in western Pennsylvania and so you had a
real movement going on there where and
we can't really call it moonshining at
the time because it was legal to make
this whiskey but it was this was before
a time than it was taxed so when the
government in 1791 put the impose the
distilled spirits tax then we started to
get people who were saying hey wait a
second this is not cool what do you try
to do to be talking about the colonial
eras and you know a big part of the
protests against the British is that the
new Americans thought they wouldn't have
to deal with this kind of stuff anymore
can you talk a little bit about the
whiskey rebellion yeah the whiskey
rebellion I think it came about because
suddenly we've just had the
Revolutionary War and then you had the
secretary of the Treasury saying hey we
Alexander Hamilton saying we need to
finance we need to pay for the
Revolutionary War debt in order to do
that we're going to impose a tax on
distilled spirits
this was something that people were very
uncomfortable with this was something
where we had just fought a war of
independence against unfair taxes and
and so suddenly to have the United
States government trying to impose this
tax people felt this was very unfair and
so there were organized protests largely
in western Pennsylvania and this is
where the Whiskey Rebellion grew out of
and so you had groups of what they they
were being called insurgents by the
federal government yes the name stick
around in different context so these
insurgents were going after tax
collectors and it became a violent
rebellion ultimately in which you had
President Washington sent out nearly
13,000 troops to quell this rebellion
and he himself led that charge out to
Peston Pennsylvania moving forward a
little prohibition ended in the 30s but
then there was more prohibition of
moonshine itself can you talk a little
bit about that
you know after prohibition a lot of
times people think well suddenly the
nation could drink again well that's not
entirely true there were still many
places throughout this country and there
is still places today that are dry so in
some states we even have dry counties
wet counties and within a dry County wet
cities you know so there's this real
holdover or hangover perhaps from
Prohibition so still you had you had
these communities where this was making
this clear on aged whiskey liquor this
was also part of cultural heritage this
wasn't just a way to make money although
it was a very good way for many people
to make money
it was very prominent in Appalachia
absolutely very prominent in Appalachia
but because liquor was still expensive
because jobs were scarce we're leading
into the Great Depression so there was
still people who needed to make money
and they relied on this family tradition
of making moonshine so this was a big
economic driver for a lot of people they
kept families afloat they kept put food
on the table you talked a little bit
about the struggles for me I was trying
to go legitimate yes well in back in you
know and we're talking in the
eighteen hundred's the mid to late-1800s
there wasn't really a movement for four
moonshiners to go legitimate per se but
they were trying to continue their
efforts to make their liquor without
being detected by the law and so it was
a real cat-and-mouse game between
revenuers and moonshiners and revenuers
were the revenue agents and these were
federal agents that came into play and
the believe it was 1861 where we had our
first income tax and liquor was taxed
and if you weren't paying that taxed you
could be arrested and so when you look
back at some of the very old the
original IRS tax records I mean every
year the IRS put out yearly bulletins
and about their activities these read
like Western novels because you have
stories of revenue agents riding on
horseback up into these hills and
valleys sniffing out the corn mash in
creeks you know really using all of
their senses and it was violent I mean
there were definitely people within
these small communities who really they
didn't feel like these moonshiners were
doing anything wrong can you talk a
little bit about how moonshining led to
the rise of NASCAR which is apparently
America's most popular spectator sport
all of you had all these people in the
south who were coming up as whiskey
tripperz that's what they called the
drivers so they were some of the most
skilled drivers around and so it was
just natural that they would become
involved in NASCAR one of the people
that I write about in my book moonshine
is a man that many people NASCAR fans
would know jr. Johnson and jr. Johnson
was one of the first inductees in the
NASCAR Hall of Fame now jr. Johnson as a
young man starting at about age 14
helped his father with his moonshine
whiskey business
so he was one of these guys who would go
out at 14 years old pre driver's license
but he knew how to drive and he would
deliver the liquor to people so he knew
how to drive fast and skillfully because
the law was after him all the time why
is moonshine culturally relevant now
because we have so many people
interested in this do-it-yourself
movement sort of back to these original
food
and in drink in this country and so it's
in order to make something you know to
make this liquor on your own is really
exciting to a lot of people it's under
the radar it's still against the law
remains against the law to make
distilled spirits even the wine and beer
you can you can make legally the title
of the book refers to moonshine as
America's most infamous liquor is there
a push for exporting moonshine to the
rest of the world is there an interest
in it well as we you know moonshine has
a long history in the United States and
because of that I think it has this
mystique that I think is appealing to
people in other countries and in fact I
do know that the folks at Kings County
distillery in Brooklyn which is the
distillery near where I live in Brooklyn
they're starting to export some of their
moonshine to Japan and so there's a real
interest in American culture and this is
certainly a deep deep part of American
culture thanks so much for talking to us
Jamie Joyce the author of moonshine a
cultural history of America's infamous
liquor for recent TV i'm anthony fisher